you are like a Moschino Barbie doll
dream Barbie core I'm more of like
Barbie's mother but I'll take it oh no
can I drew can I keep her can I keep her
can I keep
yes yes I will say that I just got these
they're amazing well
I'd like me to Spill the tea on who's
before I came to your show yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes Ariana Grande no
okay since we're talking about Ariana
Grande
um she writes the forward in your book
which is so beautifully written but you
know you guys have a beautiful past
together I love this story of how you
met when she was just a little girl
right 10 years old 10 years old look
there's the picture we have it that's
the moment she saw you in Wicked right
and she got to go backstage she got to
go backstage and shoot even then she was
like hi I want to play Glinda it's the
same boys we both have the same voices
even today
um she she came backstage with her Nona
and her mama and she sang and then I was
like you have to have something in mind
because I knew she was gonna make it you
did and I gave her like bath soaps and a
plastic wand I was just like hair
just take it you know and then her dog
peed on my couch and I thought wow
A Moment Like This girlfriend you did I
knew she had something special
now but to know
in the film she's playing England yeah
they're shooting it right now that's
such a happening
well that for me goes into another
Segway if you will
um it's ironic that you say but I I'm no
philosopher but I've got thoughts you
really do I know and your outlook on
life is so
magnanimous and what I was reading
um when I was doing the cold open was
about the part where they came to you
um on the Oprah Winfrey Show
um to see if you wanted to meet your
mother
and
it really struck me personally because
I've thought a lot about like should I
talk to my mom on this show and you want
to like almost cut yourself open in the
most beautiful metaphorical way and sort
of
um not have any of those walls
um but we have to because we're human
yeah yeah
[Music]
and what did you do in that moment how
did you handle that when that was that
well I just said no I can't do that I I
loved I love Oprah I wanted to do it so
bad but I just thought that's a private
moment and also I wasn't ready and then
the locator the guy that she overhead
started the ball rolling called me out
of the blue and he said I don't know but
I had the feeling I'm supposed to reach
out to you and tell you you need to meet
your birth mom and I said it's so weird
because I'm laying here and I'm like who
has vertigo why do I'd have eczema is my
brain okay just stuff like who talks
like a chipmunk I'd like to know and um
I met her he said I'll mediate it I said
I do want to do it and so anyway we met
in in Texas we met in Dallas I was doing
a concert there at the Dallas Opera and
I thought we'll just do two things at
once not even thinking how emotional I
walked in the door and there's this tiny
little me she's going oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh my God
oh my God and you're me and I'm you and
I was like I'm you and you're me and we
just kept repeating it like wow it was
like weird and then she said are you mad
at me
I said
you gave me life
and my my birth mom my birth mom gave me
life and my mom Gina with my mama
who raised me gave me a life so I have
nothing but gratefulness and so I write
about it
thanks for asking me yeah it's so
vulnerable this whole book is an arrow
of how to thrive it's so amazing I love
this book so much
yes and we are all fully cited you know
we're all just trying to get along we're
just all trying to get along
[Music]
thank you